[Music]
this morning we are learning about a
thriving wildlife community along one of
the world's most tense international
borders that most of us associate with
war we are talking about the
demilitarized zone also known as a dmz
it separates north and south korea
today's inhabitants are not human but
they're birds they're cats and deer who
roam free in an area where people are
not even allowed elizabeth palmer met
one man watching the wildlife from the
border who is showcasing these animals
to the world
on the banks of the imjin river
biologist kim siong looks through his
spotting scope and finds what he seeks
whitening crane white neck crane okay
a family of endangered white naped
cranes is feeding nearby
just across the river is the dmz the
demilitarized zone that marks the border
between warring north and south korea
heavily mined and patrolled by troops
from the u.s and both koreas it's a
no-go area for humans
but a refuge for animals
like the bird life which thrives in the
peace of what's technically a war zone
70 years ago the korean war pitted u.s
and south korean soldiers against the
chinese in 1953
the fighting ended in an armed standoff
with the dmz 160 miles long and two and
a half miles wide as a buffer that has
become as kim shows me a haven for all
kinds of creatures
so the military keeps people out of this
area because it's a
our artillery range basically which is
great for the animals
but i think i just heard a boom was that
a tank or somebody firing a shell
yeah
so they're shooting now not at us
kim has been photographing the creatures
that live here for years including the
amazing korean water deer with its
vampire-like fangs
rare sea eagles
and shy leopard cats
kim is on a mission
to show korean high school students how
precious wild spaces like this are in
heavily developed south korea so i think
this is a very rich source that korea is
very fortunate to have
in 2019 donald trump and north korea's
leader kim jong-un met in the dmz
those talks didn't end the armed
standoff but future ones may well
succeed which could open this pristine
area to development
instead kim tells his students and
anyone else who will listen the best
monument for peace between the korean
peoples
would be a protected home for its
animals
a dmz national park
for cbs morning's elizabeth palmer near
the dmz south korea
so i often wonder
if the world without us what would it be
like for the animals and you get a
little window into that in that two-mile
160 mile long stretch they have a good
time without us don't they you sure
enjoy it yeah i've never seen a water
deer before with vampires ever that kind
of blew my mind